et là parce que la dernière fois que tu
es venu tu avais donné ton salaire on va
en parler
ouais bien sûr tu avais dit je sais plus
combien tu es limité 7000 euros
cette manie si justement pour confirmer
tout ça comme ça ces affaires clos et on
passe à autre chose
après donc c'est 27000 euros y'a pas de
trucs parce que je sais que tf1 nous a
demandé de faire un tweet et de dire non
en fait j'ai dit une connerie je n'ai
pas pris 27 mille roubles et a jamais
fait ce tweet tu veux que je te laisse
pas passer c'est le truc c'est que c'est
vrai que tf1 m'a dit que ça se faisait
pas de parler d'argent
mais à quoi sert il je les fais certes
pour ça mais je les fais certes aussi
pour autre chose c'est que tous les
jours depuis que j balance et on dirait
que là je parle ya deux trois jours que
m'avait reçu 26 euros tous les
aventuriers qui ressort de cette saison
ou mais au delà des saisons précédentes
ils m'ont harceler le message tu es un
mytho tu nous fait passer pour de la
merde tout à fait trois jours et tu
prends 27000 nous on a fait les poteaux
et on reçoit parce que toi tu reçois tu
te prends pour qui
samassa voire tu peux le pouilly le
scooter du kop et samassa mag avait et
je m'égare dit je vais mettre ça je met
tout le monde d'accord
je me fais passer pour un mytho tant
mieux oh moi je ne suis pas alors
actionné tous les jours c'est vrai en
tout cas ce que tu dis tu as bien été
payée 27000 euros pour quatre émissions
tu as posté un tweet alors tf1 tu as
demandé de poster un tweet comme quoi tu
te rétracter et toi tu as posté
j'apprécie mon passage sur tpm paix en
compagnie de cyril de son nom mais je
précise qu'aucun en aucun cas la
production de tf1 aurait fait du
chantage pour démentir mon salaire je me
suis juste mal exprimée en oubliant de
préciser que j'avais touché 27000 euros
pour quatre émissions à ce que je me
suis dit oh non des pressions de défense
j'ai pris un subi de pression aucune
et c'est pour ça que je viens ici parce
qu'à cas en aucun cas j'ai subi de
pression mais c'est que j'ai subi des
pressions et on en espère un tweet non
ils m'ont demandé de faire un tweet pour
pas juste mais sans pression ça revient
sur le twitt maloya les gadjos évident
quand tu t'appelles tu dois bien sale
terre battue
la lega peut-être oui zidane je retiens
tu fasses en kryte concerne un koh lanta
s'il te plaît non très bien merci
obligés de faire quelque chose j'ai le
choix est le choix et j'ai décidé qu'ils
avaient raison et que je devais le faire
aussi pour pour que ça enlève toute
cette jalousie d'autres aventures et moi
cet argent là je n'ai pas volé je les
négocier et je les mérites est la preuve
voilà et avec cet argent tu t'es acheté
une belle chemise d'ailleurs à merci
merci quoi qu'ils disent oui je vais
savoir on a l'impression que tu es
famille sur vous pour d'autres émissions
ils pensent que vous êtes un bon
candidat à l'avenir pour d'autres
magruder ça car on dit et on a
l'impression vous tirer des balles dans
le pied en venant ici alors que c'est
rabaisser les aider avec ça je ne peux
pas parce qu'à chaque fois que je viens
ici j'appelle la personne qui s'occupe
vraiment de moi et elle le sait un peu
magali c'est un peu aller ici donc j'ai
tout fait pour moi l'intérêt alexis
aussi et ça l'a rejoint hier la
productrice de koh lanta exactement mais
alexia les couacs hip hop quoique unis
aujourd'hui à l'époque ronde mais elle
m'a appelé m'a dit mollahs dylan fait ce
que la peinture pour mon image et pour
nous eh bien c'est vrai alors yacine
comment karachi tout en apprenant le
salaire de dylan moi je il ya une chose
que je comprends pas c'est que je suis
au courant ou en tout cas de lgt au
courant avant je savais qu'ils tout on
avait le même contrat ouais savait qu'il
avait touché la même somme seulement il
aux capuches et 27 millions route aussi
non du tout le la chose qui est sûre
c'est que il a négocié et 20000 euros de
plus sur autre chose sur des émissions
je n'ai jamais assez c'est donc toi tu
vas faire quoi tu vas faire la villa des
coeurs brisés que j'ai déjà fait les
ninjas
mais si on gagne aussi sur autre chose
c'est à lui en fait dans quel point ils
ont tous fait faire pas à faire le
téléshopping
non mais après c'est moi je dis c'est
bien pour lui mais en fait que j'arrive
pas à comprendre c'est que nous on a
fait kolontar pour l'aventuré et et en
fait c'était même pas une question
d'argent ça serait à la limite mais
franchement c'est longtemps tu sais pas
exactement où tu étais parker ou tu fais
pas non mais c'est vrai c'est ça mais il
a eu il voit là ils étaient ils étaient
ouverts pour d'autres émissions
on lui a proposé justement un salaire
pour d'autres émissions il l'a fait mais
on dirait j'ai l'impression aujourd'hui
qu'il a fait un braquage c'est
mais c'est vrai c'est ça me tue il va
leur degré bien négocié